ante
bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen ici à bruxelles
cette semaine l'union européenne
accueille son 28e membres la croatie le
pays en récession attend beaucoup de
l'europe nous irons dans le sud du pays
à split et l'europe qui vient de
s'engager dans la négociation d'un
accord de libre-échange avec les
etats-unis un accord qui touchera tous
les aspects de notre vie quotidienne
c'était là une des télévisions
européennes faciliter le libre échange
entre les états unis et l'europe
un projet relancer mi juin par les
dirigeants du g8 en irlande du nord
une nouvelle donne pour l'économie
mondiale qui suscite l'intérêt des
télévisions européennes l'union
européenne et les etats unis ont annoncé
le début des négociations pour réaliser
un ambitieux traité sur le libre
commerce transaction
ce projet pourrait rapporter 100
millions d'euros de chaque côté de
l'atlantique la plainte de deux millions
d'emplois pourraient être créés une
manne non négligeable en période de
récession les grands de ce monde qui
accélère le calendrier
le président obama a déclaré que le
premier tour des négociations auraient
lieu à washington dès le mois prochain
ce marché transatlantique
d'investissement fera partie de mes
priorités et celle de mon administration
il est important que nous voyons juste
il faut résister à la tentation de
réduire nos ambitions ou d'éviter les
sujets compliqués dans l'unique but
d'obtenir un accord mais en france qu'en
penseront on s'inquiète pour l'exception
culturelle et on dépêche la palme des
ambassadrices pour tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé auprès des députés européens il
y a deux ans l'actrice française
bérénice bejo joie dans le film oscarisé
six artistes
maintenant elle veut protéger le cinéma
européen de la domination d'hollywood
j'ai grandi avec les films américains
j'ai grandi avec la culture américaine
et c'est très bien qu'elle existe mais
je pense que et pour eux et pour nous
c'est important d'avoir la possibilité
c'est important d'avoir une
contrebalance
alors voilà pour ce zapping signée marie
lebon l'heure nous sommes avec yannick
jadot
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
européen vous êtes du groupe des verts
est-ce que cet accord qui n'est pas
encore signé qui est en cours de
négociation entre les états unis et
l'europe est quelque chose de technique
au contraire quelque chose qui va
toucher notre vie quotidienne
ça va forcément touché notre vie
quotidien parce que ce qu'on va négocier
avec les états unis ce sont plus des
droits de douane sont plus des tarifs
parce que ça globalement le commerce est
totalement libéralisé entre les états
unis et l'europe
ce qu'on va négocier sont les règles les
règles qui régissent notre économie et
les règles qui régissent notre vivre
ensemble
par exemple en europe vous savez nous
avons une certaine conception des
services publics
nous défendons une certaine vision de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation
on refuse globalement les ogm le boeuf
aux hormones la viande chlorés donc à
toute une série de choix de société qui
vont être négociés dans cet accord et
c'est pour ça que pour notre part nous
considérons que cet accord est très
dangereux alors vous dit en fait que par
exemple le poulet chloré on sait que les
américains utilisent du chlore à la fin
de l'abattage des poulets vous dites que
les poulets chlorés les ogm le boeuf aux
hormones par exemple qui sont des choses
aujourd'hui interdites en europe vont
arriver en europe à cause de cet accord
le risque c'est que à travers la
négociation on arrive à un système où
tout ce qui est légal légitime aux états
unis devienne légale en europe
c'est systématique est ce que ça sera
l'issue de cet accord c'est ça que c'est
pas forcément automatique
mais on voit bien que pour les états
unis ces sujets sont essentiels ce
qu'ils veulent nous alimenter avec des
ogm du boeuf aux hormones de la viande
chlorés et puis on voit de notre côté ou
ce qui est sensé de notre côté une
commission européenne qui n'a jamais
caché que l'interdiction des ogm
ne lui plaisait pas et on l'a vu encore
dernièrement avec le président barroso
qui considérait que l'exception
culturelle était une un élément
totalement réactionnaire de la société
au gré de la france et est réactionnaire
et que la france était réactionnaire
donc on voit bien une commission
européenne qui croient dans les vertus
du libre-échange et qui est prêt à céder
sur des choix qui ont été
démocratiquement construit et puis en
face des états unis qui sont unis dans
leur volonté de détendre gérer leur
système de règles au marché on comprend
les craintes que vous avez mais est ce
que quand même dans une période où
l'europe est en récession d'ailleurs
c'est le seul continent du monde qui a
ici mal sur le plan économique et ce qui
serait pas comme on l'a vu par exemple
dans le reportage nécessaire et bien de
deux mètres un peu d'essence dans le
moteur pour redonner de la croissance et
créer des emplois mais il c'est là que
aussi le bât blesse du côté de la
commission puisque la commission est
sorti avec des chiffres extrêmement
précis des bénéfices qu'on aurait à
avoir cet accord prend 0,55 cent
soixante il jusqu'à dans 15 ans 545
euros précisément par ménage européen de
quatre personnes
le problème c'est que vous n'avez pas
d'économistes sérieux qui justifie ces
chiffres sont des chiffres totalement
hallucinant et ça fait 15 ans que la
commission à chaque négociation à chaque
le projet de dérégulation nous dit ça va
nous apporter de la croissance
le problème c'est que si toutes ces
estimations passé de la commission
s'étaient révélées exactes
aujourd'hui on a une croissance chinoise
il est quand même paradoxal que une
crise qui est aussi la crise du libre
échange de l'art et des régulations du
libéralisme on nous propose de sortir de
cette crise en appliquant la même
recette qui nous a conduit à ces petits
bouts dit globalement c'est que cet
accord avant même que en fait finalement
la négociation est vraiment débuter cet
accord est mauvais cet accord est
mauvais parce que il se place dans un
contexte politique qui n'est pas bon que
moi on discute entre l'europe et les
états unis sur l'harmonisation par le
haut de nos normes sociales de normes
environnementales de normes sanitaires
ça serait une bonne chose mais on voit
des deux côtés l'idée c'est plutôt de
déréguler
de déconstruire ces normes plutôt que de
les renforcer
on voit bien aussi l'objectif qui est
toujours amené de dire ça c'est un bloc
à quantic contre l'émergence de la chine
par exemple
mais on a vu que sur les panneaux
photovoltaïques madame merkel a fait
alliance avec la chine et a fait entrer
d'une certaine façon la dictature
corrompue du parti communiste chinois à
la table du conseil européen donc tous
ces arguments là ne fonctionne pas cet
accord c'est le résultat entre cameron
qui veut faire un grand marché
transatlantique sans politique et madame
merkel qui ne défend aujourd'hui
malheureusement que ses intérêts
commerciaux la chine à la table du
conseil européen vous êtes vous êtes un
peu dans le symbole quand même on est
dans le symbole mais à partir du moment
où la chine arrive à faire pression sur
un certain nombre de pays européens en
les menaçant de rétorsion sur leur
investi sur les investissements qu'elle
pourrait faire et donc ces pays là ne
veulent pas de mesures antidumping que
l'allemagne fait alliance avec la chine
on voit que la chine a réussi à diviser
l'europe et l'europe n'est jamais aussi
faible que quand elle est divisée
alors on parlait d'un mot tout à l'heure
on disait réactionnaire c'est ce qu'il
avait dit il ya quelques jours josé
manuel barroso le président de la
commission européenne à propos de la
france
il ya eu des noms d'oiseaux qui ont qui
ont fusé comme ça entre la france et ici
à bruxelles carburant du front national
a dit arnaud montebourg
chauvinisme a répondu la commission
européenne qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que s qui est un fond de vrai
dans ce que les responsables français
fssa aussi monsieur bartolone qui ans
qui en rajoute
est ce qu'il ya un fond de vrai dans les
accusations des responsables socialistes
français depuis le début de cette
mandature et dans la précédente on a
combattu
barroso sur sa ligne politique il accuse
les écologistes représailles le registre
on a on a même fait campagne en 2009
pour éviter d'avoir de nouveau josé
manuel barroso comme président de la
commission
mais on a aussi combattu monsieur
barroso parce que c'est un président
servile des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens
si le
j'ai européen qui se négocie en ce
moment est en régression qui ne nous
pâte qui ne nous permet pas de faire les
investissements du futur c'est aussi
parce que les états ont décidé que ce
budget devait en régression sont les
états qui ont donné mandat à la
commission européenne pour négocier ce
mauvais accord de libre échange avec les
états unis
donc il est trop facile bouc émissaire
de prendre la commission comme un bouc
émissaire
la france doit peser en europe doit
arrêter d'être sur la défensive
vis-à-vis de madame merkel ou vis-à-vis
de monsieur cameron
la commission européenne c'est un
exécutif
que ce soit aujourd'hui un exécutif
libéral-conservateur c'est évident mais
les ordres le donneur d'ordres ça reste
le conseil européen que la france assume
ses responsables de la commission
européenne est ce que monsieur barroso
sont à la solde des états unis
je crois pas je crois pas qu'il soit la
solde des états unis
évidemment la commission européenne
croit dans les vertus du libre-échange
il croit qu'il suffit même de
libéraliser de manière unilatérale d'un
côté pour apporter du bien-être c'est
faux aujourd'hui dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui c'est à l'opposé de ce que
pensent les américains mais il est
évident aussi que monsieur barroso qui
aura fini son mandat dans à peu près un
an est aussi candidats à l'otan ou au
secrétariat général des nations unies et
que pour ça il aura besoin du soutien
des états unis
mais monsieur barroso c'est pas une
surprise on l'avait vu sur la guerre en
irak et un atlantiste et comme les
britanniques qui préfèrent l'alliance
avec les etats-unis qu'une europe forte
merci yannick jadot d'avoir accepté
notre invitation va rester dans ce sujet
on va recevoir dans un instant philippe
ricard qu'elle correspondant du journal
le monde ici à bruxelles et nous allons
justement voir à quel point le torchon
brûle entre paris et bruxelles regarder
tout a commencé il ya plusieurs semaines
la commission évoque les réformes
structurelles à mener en france
réforme des retraites coût du travail
paris bomber le torse et souffle que
bruxelles n'a pas à lui dicter sa
conduite
quand le gouvernement français obtient
de garantir l'exception culturelle dans
l'accord de libre-échange europe etats
unis c'est barroso qui tacle et taxes
jarry de réactionnaire alors quand
arnaud montebourg le bien nommé ministre
du redressement productif répondent à
l'invectivé
ça donne ça mais monsieur barroso est le
carburant du front national ambiance
cécile duflot alain juppé plusieurs
responsables politiques français montent
aussi au créneau et tape sur le
président de la commission loin de
calmer le jeu
il répond il serait bon que certains
responsables politiques comprennent que
ce n'est pas en attaquant l'europe et en
essayant de faire de la commission le
bouc émissaire de ses propres
difficultés qu'ils allons arriver très
loin on s'était pourtant bien habituée
aux éclats de voix entre paris et
bruxelles sous l'ère de nicolas sarkozy
mais là on frôle la sortie de piste non
il faut dire qu'entre la commission
européenne à dominante libérales et
conservatrices et la france et son
gouvernement social-démocrate la
cohabitation n'est pas simple et quand
même encore un peu et on attaque les
noms d'oiseaux alors le torchon
brûle-t-il entre paris et bruxelles
voilà pour ce billet de nora hamadi
philippe ricard bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le correspondant du journal le
monde dont vous suivez les affaires
européennes
comment vous expliquez que le ton soit
monté comme ça très fortement en
quelques jours entre paris et bruxelles
pourquoi maintenant il ya quand même un
certain nombre de contentieux qui sont
apparues le premier c'est effectivement
la recommandation de la commission
européenne qui était beaucoup plus
précise que l'année précédente en
particulier sur les retraites françois
hollande a mis en avant la souveraineté
de la france finalement pour dire c'est
à nous de décider la commission a n'a
pas trop peu intrusive
le second c'est l'accord de libre
échange et ce fameux cette fameuse
exception culturelle autant de
deux situations où en fait on sent bien
des différences d'approché dans le
rythme des réformes dans l'ampleur du
libre échange pour sortir de la crise
économique l'europe connaît voilà donc
il ya des dossiers quand même qu'ils
sont assez est resté conflictuelle épi
plus largement sa ce s'inscrit aussi
dans un vaste débat une vaste
redistribution des pouvoirs en europe où
les états cherchent toujours plus en
particulier la france et l'allemagne à
reprendre le contrôle sur la commission
européenne qui est une instance qui
soient jugés trop peu efficace notamment
vu de berlin dans la lutte contre le
chômage des jeunes le redressement des
pays en difficulté soient jugés trop
technocratique
vu de paris où on veut précisément avoir
la main sur les réformes que l'on fait
aussi sous la contrainte européenne on
évoqués dans le reportage les
différences de bord politique évidemment
entre un gouvernement socialiste et une
commission et puis de toute façon
l'ensemble des des gouvernants européens
plutôt plutôt à droite est-ce que ça ça
joue aussi sa joue mais je ne pense pas
que ce soit le ressort principal est ce
que ça aurait pu éclater plus tôt alors
de toute façon bad parfois on était un
petit peu sur les mêmes tensions du
temps de nicolas sarkozy également à
l'égard de la commission européenne même
si lui avait beaucoup plus de proximité
avec josé manuel barroso naturellement
du fait des idées conservatrices c'est
la même famille politique entre eux aux
landais barroso il n'y a pas cette
complicité ovadia naturel mais je crois
que les ressorts de cette cette
virulence de ces de ces différents
moments extrêmement forts en fait entre
paris et bruxelles actuellement sont à
chercher de façon beaucoup plus large en
fait est ce que cette position très dure
de la france et de l'ensemble des
responsables politiques français de
gauche parce que par exemple claude
bartolone a également été dur vis-à-vis
de josé manuel barroso est-ce que ça
renforce la position de la france qui
marque des points sur le plan européen
ou est-ce qu'au contraire dans les mois
qui viennent finalement la france à ceux
de se trouver affaibli
ici à bruxelles toute façon la france
part pas d'une position extrêmement
forte en ce moment ils tandonnet ses
difficultés économiques étant donnée la
toute puissance de l'allemagne au sein
de la zone euro
il est très clair toute façon que paris
ça soit sous nicolas sarkozy comme
françois hollande et ça c'est peut-être
accrue depuis l'élection du président
françois hollande parce que les
difficultés économiques se sont accrus
le décrochage avec l'allemagne est
d'autant plus fort la france ne part pas
d'une position extrêmement forte
il faut quand même constater que depuis
un an depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
françois hollande celui ci avait quand
même essayer d'avoir des relations les
plus polis possible avec la commission
européenne allant chez plutôt bien
d'ailleurs
et ça marchait plutôt bien de manière
notamment à obtenir un peu plus de délai
pour assainir les comptes publics en
france et que sur ce plan là il ya de
vrais acquis il ya un vrai dialogue
quand même il n'y a pas que cette
ambiance de crise il ya eu quand même
certaines avancées et j'ai l'impression
quand même que du côté notamment de la
commission européenne de certaines
institutions
autant on est un petit peu sous le choc
de l'offensive française sur certains
domaines très emblématique
autant on attend toujours beaucoup en
fait de françois hollande dans sa
volonté apparente à afficher au moins à
paris de réformer autant que possible la
france et on veut on veut croire que il
utilise parfois un petit peu la bande
européenne pour critiquer barroso
notamment pour gagner des marges de
manoeuvre en france et on attend des
résultats notamment au bout des deux ans
de délai supplémentaire
donc je trouve qu'il ya eu quand même
une dialogue est pas totalement
terminez rompu entre paris et alors il y
a philippe guérin un dossier important
si l'élargissement de l'europe dans
quelques jours l'europe n'aura plus 27
états membres mais 28 le 28e c'est la
croatie
d'abord merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et on va partir ensemble à
split où on va voir que la croatie est
un pays qui entrent dans l'europe mais
qui sort également de trois années de
récession
regardez ce reportage à split il est
signé jérôme rabier
avec ses 1800 km de littoral son
patrimoine culturel et ses vieilles
villes conserver la croatie a tout du
décor idéal de carte postale
à deux heures de paris en avion la
région de la dalmatie et sa capitale
split font figure de destination rêvée
pour les européens en quête de soleil de
balades touristiques
on a quand même ici un magnifique
panorama sur split sur cette forteresse
de clis deux fois millénaire des travaux
de réhabilitation sont en cours avec
l'aide de fonds de préadhésion que la
croatie tous depuis quelques années les
travaux ont commencé il y a trois ans
environ avec cette portion murale qui
était totalement démolies maintenant il
travaille à l'intérieur et en os il est
prévu d'installer la salle d'accueil du
préfet de la région
le joug panne pour la réception des
délégations étrangères
et là en dessous ce sera le musée de la
dalmatie intermat
pour cette ville historique qu'est clis
c'est vraiment très important d'avoir pu
commencer la rénovation de la forteresse
et nous espérons poursuivre avec les
fonds européens une fois notre entrée
dans l'union européenne
vraiment effective comme on dépend du
tourisme
ça va permettre de développer des
magasins de souvenirs des cafés des
restaurants car la situation économique
est ici comme dans toute l'europe
pas vraiment au beau fixe
en récession depuis 2009 la croatie
compte sur son entrée dans l'union
européenne et les fonds qui en découlent
pour enfin rebondir
le tourisme est le principal moteur
économique du pays
ils représentent presque 20% du pib
alors c'est naturellement vers ce
secteur que la quasi totalité des
financements seront orientées
oct l'un des projets consistent à
développer la capacité d'accueil
touristique mais aussi à créer quatre
écoles de formation hôtelière dans la
région d'almaty on renforcera ainsi
notre attractivité avec la crise
actuelle
on n'a pas de quoi financer ses projets
nous attendons donc vraiment que
l'europe nous aident pour ses projets
d'importance stratégique
une attente forte mais qui a aussi ses
contreparties
la croatie a dû répondre aux exigences
de bruxelles pour intégrer l'union
européenne première exigence l'ouverture
à la concurrence et la fin des
subventions directes
les chantiers navals autres secteurs
importants de l'économie croate sont les
premiers concernés les autorités ont
alors choisi la privatisation totale du
secteur à split
un seul repreneur s'est présentée la
société dit va racheter l'intégralité du
chantier pour cinq cent mille euros
une bouchée de pain vive était et est la
seule chance de reprise pour la survie
de l'activité
donc on a fait beaucoup d'efforts durant
cette période de privatisation on a
rempli toutes les obligations et trois
fois
la commission européenne a approuvé
notre plan de restructuration
donc on est très satisfait de cela au 31
mai dernier la quasi totalité des 3500
salariés ont été licenciés
seuls 2000 seront réembauchés
mais pas nécessairement au même salaire
une casse sociale qui désespère les
ouvriers ici le taux de chômage dépasse
les 20% genre mais ça me fait vraiment
de la peine
après 29 ans de travail là bas je vois
comment les travailleurs et notamment
les plus anciens résonne et on sent
clairement grandir le sentiment de
révolte
risto toc les travailleurs ne
comprennent pas pourquoi le gouvernement
croate accepte toutes les exigences de
la commission européenne
il pense qu'il aurait dû respecter la
position de ces travailleurs de ses
citoyens car on peut dire que la région
dépend de la construction navale et de
ce chantier en particulier une situation
sociale qui peut expliquer le peu
d'engouement des croates lors du
référendum d'adhésion à l'union
européenne en 2012 -2 45% d'entre eux
s'étaient déplacés pour voter
vingt ans après la guerre de yougoslavie
ce jeune pays de 4 millions d'habitants
reste imprégnée de référence
nationaliste il faudra du temps avant de
voir naître un véritable sentiment
europe et voilà ces images de la côte
dalmate reportage signé jérôme rabier et
nous accueillons un futur député
européen de croatie andrei plein kovic
bonjour bonjour est actuellement le
statut d'observateur jusqu'au 1er
juillet 1er juillet vous devenez un
nouveau député européen croate vous avez
été élu dans votre pays le 14 avril
dernier
votre pays devient le 28e membre de
l'union européenne
il attend sans doute beaucoup de l'union
mais que va apporter la croatie à
l'europe
d'abord nous sommes très contents que
finalement de chez main qui était très
longue que de notre point de vue c'est à
dire 20 ans après notre indépendance que
nous sommes finalement arrivés à ce
stade de devenir le 28e membre de
l'union européenne après beaucoup des
réformes beaucoup de négociations et
beaucoup de conditions exigeantes la
croatie c'est un jeune pays mec mais
aussi un pays très très beau quand vous
avez vu déjà ses ancêtres et portage à
un pays qui porte sa culture sa richesse
ses traditions son identité sa côte
adriatique qui fait partie de la
méditerranée aussi sa dimension
danubienne elle porte aussi 4,4 millions
d'habitants qui sont près d'être des
européens enthousiastes
alors c'est sans doute des richesses
mais au-delà de cette image un peu de
cartes postales sur le plan économique
comme en va aujourd'hui le pays
on a vu qu'en 2009 il était complètement
dans la crise qu'est ce qui lui a permis
de se relever aussi vite
la croatie a eu ces années très
important de points de vue de croissance
économique pendant la dernière décennie
entre 2003 jusqu'à 2008
minutes mais comme partout après la
grande crise financière et économique
on a senti des conséquences qui ont fait
une certaine chute du croissant c'est
aussi une augmentation de chômage ça
c'est quelque chose qui est un peu
similaire dans tous les pays de l'europe
centrale et orientale
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
faire une consolidation fiscale de
consolider notre cadre juridique notre
cadre fiscal est aussi de faire pays
beaucoup plus d'être attractif pour les
investisseurs étrangers comme ça que
nous pouvons avoir une conjoncture
économique
une croissance qui pourrait faciliter et
améliorer la vie de nos citoyens vous
voyez les plans drastiques qui sont
demandé à certains pays
européen qu'on qualifie de mauvais élève
vous n'avez pas peur on demande un jour
peut-être la même chose à votre pays
s'il n'a pas fait suffisamment d'efforts
non je crois qu'il faut savoir que
maintenant comme la commission vous dit
vous êtes près de l'entrée dans l'union
européenne ça veut dire qu'il y avait
beaucoup de gens beaucoup d experts qui
ont regardé chaque détail de notre état
de préparation mais vous même vous avez
fait partie des vous avez suivi de près
ses négociations puisque vous étiez
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
étrangères
absolument tous les airs vie gagnant
2010 2011
alors nous avons fait beaucoup de
réformes pour être aussi bien je dirais
dans le contexte actuel de l'union
européenne
nous avons déjà fait partie de cette
semestre européen
cette système de la contrôler ex ante
est de la coordination c'est toujours
documents concernant le budget de la
croatie sont transmis transmis à la
presse michel avant que par exemple au
parlement croate pour faire une
consultation est ce que nos finances
publiques sont bien consolider ce qu'il
n'y a pas trop de dettes etc
oui aujourd'hui la croatie est plutôt un
bon élève
je dirais que nous sommes prêts si nous
n'étions pas prêts je dirais que la
décision de conseil n'aurait pas
positive est tous les pays n'auront pas
ratifié notre traité d'adhésion temps
alors le croatie est un état préparer
pour devenir le 28e membre
on verra après est ce que nous sommes
dans la capacité de réagir à tous les
pressions de la compétitivité de marché
intérieur c'est ça qui compte pour nos
opérateurs économiques qui est
une certaine exigence est une exigence
est depuis plus important alors y avait
un référendum d'adhésion auprès de la
population mais une partie de la
population estime que l'europe rejette
un peu cette adhésion estime que
l'europe va apporter de plus d'ennuis
que de solutions il ya un sentiment
national croate assez fort est ce que
vous prenez en compte tous et tous ces
paramètres
bien sûr mais il faut se souvenir que
nous avons eue le référendum du 22
janvier 2012 que les résultats étaient
66% pour l'entrée et 33 contre les taux
de participation s'était 43% alors il ya
une décision très légitime de majorité
de la population croître
il y avait toujours un grand consensus
politique de doute tous les partis
parlementaires quand on a ratifié un
autre traité d'adhésion par la main
droite
tous les députés étaient pour alors il
ya un consensus politique de pommes de
mainstream jeu des règles dans la
croatie il n'y a bien sûr de la
démocratie les voix qui sont les voir
opposants qui ne sont pas contents avec
l'état de l'union européenne actuelle
qui croient peut être que seulement 20
ans après l'indépendance nous sommes en
train déjà de faire partie d'une autre
sorte du état supranational une
structure supranationale
mais moi je crois parce que je suis
aussi membre d'une partie qui fait
qu'ils aient des lois démocratiques zain
et servir de modèle aux critiques notent
une partie qui est sans doute ppe
majorité majoritaire au parlement
européen on croit au projet européen
on croit que la le fait que nous serons
membres va nous apporter des bénéfices
aux non-citoyens aux nouvelles
générations à notre économie à notre
niveau de développement social
économique là on parle comme d'un
problème qui concerne votre pays mais
d'autres aussi mais notamment la croatie
la corruption qui serait encore
importante est ce qu'il ya des mesures
qui sont prises pour lutter contre ce
fléau
c'est vrai que la corruption c'est un
phénomène qui était
je dirais qu'à caractéristiques dans les
pays de la transition
plus peut-être que dans l'est déjà
démocratie consolidée mais il n'y a pas
personne pays qui sont emule pour que
cette phénomène nous l'europe centrale
et orientale dans toute la région des
balkans
je dirais que c'est pas seulement un
problème exclusivement chlorate c'est
vrai que c'était assez important mais il
y a une forte volonté politique c'était
une des priorités de notre dernière
gouvernements les institutions qui sont
chargés de lutter contre la contre la
corruption c'est le procureur général
c'est bureau spécial de pro creux qui ne
sont plus qu avec la corruption et le
contre le crime organisé la police la
justice
il ya tellement de procès qui sont déjà
un train et on laisse au cours de
décider si quelqu'un était coupable ou
non mais vraiment c'est un phénomène qui
n'est pas socialement acceptable la
création et bien merci beaucoup en bref
plein de corriger d'avoir été avec nous
vous souhaite la bienvenue ici comme
nouveau député européen on se reverra
très bientôt merci de nous avoir accordé
cette interview en français merci c'est
la fin de cette émission la dernière
émission de rentrée de dos de l'année on
se retrouve pour une nouvelle session
l'an prochain merci à tous et à toute
l'équipe
pascal serge adeline julie et mco et à
très bientôt très bonnes vacances sur
les chaînes parlementaires